[Müzik]
Merhaba Hoş geldiniz güzel İzmir
1957 yılında genç bir bilim insanı
İngiltere'de Sessiz sedasız King
challenge'da öldü çalıştığı röntgen
ışınlarının etkisiyle yumurtalık kanseri
olduğu daha sonra saptandı öldüğünde
henüz 37 yaşındaydı üzerinde çalıştığı
işlerden birinin fotoğrafı kendisinden
Habersizce laboratuvarda çalışan erkek
meslektaşı tarafından Habersizce başka
yerlere çekilip yollanmıştı intihal
demek istemiyorum hırsızlık da demek
istemiyorum Habersizce yollanmıştır
diyorum Yorumu size bırakıyorum Bu
kadının adı rosi'nin franklindi
öldüğünde O sadece 37 yaşındaydı bilim
tarihine fotoğraf 51 olarak geçen bu
fotoğraf insanlık tarihini uygarlığı
değiştirecek DNA çift sarmal molekülünün
buluşunda çok önemli bir aşamaya sahipti
bundan habersizken öldü
rozion Franklin çocukluğundan beri
etrafında günlük yaşamla bilimin
birbirinden ayrılmaz olduğunu
hissediyorum diyen bir kızdı
1950'lerde İngiltere dahil Dünyada pek
çok yerde bir kadının bilimle uğraşması
çok alışıldık bir şey değildi Kendisi
çok önemli bir buluşa katkısı olduğunu
bilmeden öldü ve uzun yıllar unutuldu
1962 yılında onun ölümünden Birkaç yıl
sonra Watson Crick ve wilkins adında 3
erkek bilim adamının DNA sarmalıyla
ilgili buluşu nedeniyle Nobel Tıp ödülü
aldığını biliyoruz
bu ödülün sebebi şuydu DNA'nın çekirdek
yapısını onların nesilden nesile geçen
biyolojik bilgisindeki rolü ve
kapasitesini buldukları için
kazandıkları söylenmişti DNA çift sarmal
molekülü bulunduktan sonra dünya Artık
eskisi gibi olmadı gıdadan tıba
biyolojiden
zooloji'ye botaniği hayatımız tamamen
değişti yani hayatın Aslında sırrını
çözmüşlerdi ve bu DNA sarmalının bütün
canlılarda olduğunu bilmemiz bizim
insanlıkla ilgili kültürel anlayışımızla
değiştirdi hepimiz aynı aileden
geliyorduk Bundan yıllar sonra
Türkiye'de liseli kız biyolojik
kitabında gördüğü DNA çift sarmal
fotoğrafına aşık oldu bu size komik
gelebilir ama Ben şahidim bunu gördükten
sonra hayatın sırrını çözeceğini
inanmıştı bu
Türkiye'de Doğan ve Türkiye'de Liseye
giden o genç kız arasında aslında
aslında duygusal ve zihinsel bir
birliktelik vardı Ve hayatın sırrını
kavrama merakı yüzünden biyolog olmaya
karar verdi
sadece Türkiye'de o sırada Hacettepe
Üniversitesi'nde Elektron mikroskobu
olduğu için Hacettepe Üniversitesi'nde
biyoloji okumaya karar verdi bu kız
bendim ve doğal olarak
bu erkek 3 erkek bilim adamı benim rol
modellerinden birisi oldu onlara çok
Hayrandım Çünkü çok önemli bir buluş
yapmışlardı
elbette
bir Fotoğrafla bir o çalınan Fotoğrafla
bu buluşun meydana geldiğini henüz
bilmiyordum rol modeller çok önemli
Şimdi onlar benim rol modelimdi
ikonumdu ya da başka bir işle dedim rol
modellere bakarak bir toplumun gelecekte
çocuklarına sunduğu rol modelleri ile
bir toplumun Gelecekte nasıl bir dünya
ve kültür kurmak istediğini çok iyi
anlarız şu anda bakın çocuklarımıza ve
gençlerimize sunulan rol modelleri
Bundan 20 yıl önce sunulanları
Cumhuriyet kuşağında sunulanlara bakın
her şeyin ne kadar siyasi ve planlı
olduğunu anlayacaksınız ve gençlikte
çocuklukta hepimizin rol modellere
ihtiyacı vardır kişiliğinizin
gelişmesinde kime benzemek istediğimiz
onun hangi değerleri sunduğu hangi
ahlaki etik değerleri savunduğu çok
önemli kişilik Yapı taşımızdır Annem
Cumhuriyet kadınlarından biriydi ve
onlar cumhuriyetin kadınlara verdiği
kazanımları ya da elde ettikleri
kazanımları çok farkında olan kadınlardı
o yüzden rol modelleri de farkındaydı
bana küçükken internetin olmadığı
dönemde biliyorsunuz posta puluyla
yalayarak pulları zarfa yapıştırıp
postanelerden yollardık o pullardan iki
tanesinin üzerinde iki kadını sürekli
bana gösterirdi henüz ilkokula
gitmediğim yaşlar Demek ki 4-5 yaşları
olmalı Bak bu iki kadın çok önemli derdi
biliyorsunuz ilk rol modellerimiz
annelerimiz ve babalarımızdır onların
beğendiği hayran olduğu şeyi bizle
yapmak isteriz Çünkü annemiz bizi de ya
da Babamız bizi de beğenecektir
annemin gösterdiği iki kadından birisi
Madam curidi bir uluslararası konferans
için çekilmiş toplu fotoğrafın içinde
Bak bu adam küre Dünyada hiçbir erkeğin
başaramadığı bir şeyi başardı iki kere
Nobel fizik ve Kimya ödülünü kazandı
demiştir daha sonraki yıllarda Madam
kürenin Aslında Polonya'dan Fransa'ya
göçen Ve Fransa'da Batı Avrupa'da
kolonyalı olduğu için hep aşağı alandı
küçük Görüldüğü bir kadın olduğu için
kongrelere davet edilmediği çok
sıkıntılı bir hayat yaşadığını öğrendim
Ama madem şöyle benim çocukluk
rol modellerinden biriydi ikinci kadın
pullarda resmi olan Halide Edip adı
vardı Halide Edip adıvarı Sadece iyi bir
yazar olduğu için değil romanlarından
birisi Sinekli bakkalın ana karakteri de
annemin adıyla aynı olduğu için değil
Halide Edip adıvar'ı dünyada hiç eşi
benzeri olmayan bir direniş ve özgürlük
savaşı olan Kurtuluş Savaşı'na da bizzat
kendisinin cephede savaşarak katılmış
bir kadın olduğuyla övünürdü Böylece
aslında çocuğunuza anlatmasanızda çocuk
annenizin veya babanızın size rol modeli
olarak gösterdiği kişilerin karakter
özelliklerini anlamaya başlıyor Bu iki
kadın da sadece zeki ve Azimli değildi
Çok cesurdu ve mücadele ediyorlardı Ne
için mücadele ediyorlardı inandıkları
şey için
Böylece benim Watson Crick ve wilkans'a
olan rol model hayranlığımı da biraz
anlatmış oluyorum çocukken biraz rosalin
franklin'e benzediğimi söyledim Benim de
Hayatta yapmak istediğim heyecanla
beklediğim şeyler arasında kızlara
önerilen şeyler dışında biliyorsunuz
onları ne olduğunu çok kısıtlı Ben
dünyaya gezmek değişik ülkeleri görmek
kitaplar yazmak isteyen bir çocuktum ve
bilime de aşıktım Aslında benim gibi
çocuklar Kız çocukları çok fazladır
Belki sizin kucağınızdaki kız da öyle
Bu çocukların kızların Aslında ergenliğe
kadar okullarda matematik ve bilimde
Oğlan çocuklarından daha önde olduğunu
değişik
araştırmalardan biliyoruz ne oluyorsa
ergenlikte oluyor kızlara sen kızsın sen
bunu yapma yapmamalısın şeklindeki
davranışlarla hızları geriye çekiyoruz o
yüzden bir kadının matematikte sayısalda
herhangi bir alanda çok büyük işler
başarması aslında tabiatında olan bir
şey Toplumsal olarak ona biçtiğimiz
roller nedeniyle bunu başarmaları
engelleniyor
Bu yüzden ben biyoloji okumaya Hacettepe
Üniversitesi'nde başladım Çünkü Elektron
mikroskobu vardı bende DNA sarmalı
görecektim daha sonra
değişik ülkelerde burs alarak dünyaya
gezme şansı buldum bu tabi çok çalışmayı
gerektiren bir şey Ama eğer çok
istiyorsanız yapabiliyorsunuz Böylece
aslında Siz de bazı gençler için rol
modeli olmaya başlıyorsunuz bunu
planlamıyorsunuz rol modeli aslında
kendi istediği şeyi çocukluğunda hayal
ettiği şeyleri başarmaya başlayan
insanlardır hepimizin hayatında da
vardır
1980'lerin ortasında kadın hareketinin
en canlı olduğu yıllarda Amerika
Birleşik Devletleri'nde Üniversitesinde
Toplum Sağlığı ve çevre sağlığı gibi bir
çalışıyordum bu da dünyadaki kadın
hareketinin en hareketlendiği dönemde o
dönemin o dönemde çok şey öğrendim asıl
öğrendiğim en önemli şey kadınların
destek olduğunda birbirine dayanışma
gösterdiğinde ve iletişim kurduklarında
güçlerini ilk defa belki insanlık
tarihinde farkına varmış olmalıydı İşte
o yıllarda Belki bu feminist hareket
nedeniyle rosion Franklin hakkında
kitaplar yazılmaya başlandı Ben de adını
ilk defa o zaman duydum özellikle
arkadaşları onunla ilgili kitaplar
yazdılar ve Aslında
welconsın bu Watson Crick ve
wilkins'taki 3 erkekten birisinin onun
meslektaşı olarak aynı laboratuvarda
kings'ta çalıştığı ortaya çıktı ve
özellikle o yıllarda
İngiltere'de bile kadınların erkeklerle
birlikte meslektaşlarıyla birlikte öğle
yemeğine aynı yerde yasak olduğunu
öğrendim bu şimdi bize şaka gibi geliyor
ama gerçekten böyle aynı yıllarda kendi
annemden biliyorum Türkiye
Cumhuriyeti'nde Üniversite okuyabilen
Devlet okullarında okuyabilen kızlar ve
oğlanlar aynı yemekhanede yemek
yiyebiliyorlardı Bunlar çok önemli
bilgiler Çünkü insan bir defa başarırsa
yeniden Başarır bunu hiç unutmayın her
konuda toplumsal konuda da bir defa
Başaran özel hayatında da bir defa
Başaran yine Başarır hiçbir başarıyı
küçük görmeyin
Öğle yemeğinde erkeklerle birlikte
yemesi yasak olduğu için Laboratuvardan
ayrıldığı sırada rosi'nin Franklin'in
fotoğraf 51 adındaki o Röntgen filmini
çekip gizlice bu konuda çalışma yapan
Watson ve kroki yolladı ortaya çıkıyor
Şu anda wildınız Hayatta bunu hala
reddetse de bazı
belgelerde resmi bunu yaptığına dair
bulgular var daha sonra yazılan
kitaplarda bugün Mobbing denen Aslında
psikolojik tacizin de rosaline yapıldığı
ve kendisinin Aslında çok geçimsiz
tatsız tuzsuz bir kadın olduğu
söyleniyor O da bizim aklımıza Cadı
kavramına doğrusu getiriyor Çünkü
biliyorsunuz Cadı diye yakılan
kadınların hiçbiri aptal değildi hep en
zeki kadınları en akıllıları Cadı diye
yaptılar suçladılar bir sesinizin
duyulmasını istediğinizde Cadı olmayı
göze almanız gerekiyor Ben de İleride
Cadılık makamı diye bir kitap yazmayı
çok heves ediyorum en son yazılan
kitaplardan birisi Ee rosene Franklin
ile ilgili
Amerikalı bir yazar tarafından hayatın
Sırrı başlığıyla yazıldı orada Wild
Angeles ile yapılan bir söyleşide
sonunda artık işi
kabalığa ve küfre vardır dair de bu
kitabın Adını da verebilirim size
bilgiler var elimizde bütün bunlar
olurken
kalsagan adında bir astrofizikçiden
bahsetmek istiyorum Yani bütün erkek
bilimciler
kötü niyetlidir bütün kadınlar çok
zekidir anlamında bir şey anlatmadığımın
altını çizmek istiyorum 1972 yılında
NASA bir araştırma yapıyor bu
araştırmada olası insan dışı canlıların
uzaydaki canlıların insan uygarlığını
tanıması için nasıl bir sembol
kullanabiliriz diye bir araştırma var
bayılıyorum Keşke bir gün Türkiye
Cumhuriyeti'nde de böyle araştırmalar
olsa ilk okullarda çocuklarımıza insan
dışı canlıların yani uzaylıların bizi
anlaması için Kendimizi nasıl tarif
ederiz Hadi bakalım bir resim yapın bir
yarışmalar açılsa düşünebiliyor musunuz
nelerin çıkabileceğini Çünkü Anadolu
gibi Hitit uygarlığından sümerlere kadar
birçok uygarlığın geçtiği ve bizim o
Masallar o öyküler halı desen kilimleri
türküleri ve şiirleriyle büyüdüğümüz bu
ortamda inanılmaz bir zenginlik var
Yeter ki önümüz açılsın Yeter ki Özgür
düşünebilelim düşünme suç olmasın
NASA'nın açtığı bu yarışmada yarışma
demeyin bir araştırmada daha çok bilim
kurgu yazarları ve bilimciler
katılıyorlar ve bana göre çok dar
görüşlü bir zihniyetle insanlığın insan
uygarlığının burada ana kelime insan
uygarlığı yani Fransız uygarlığı Türk
uygarlığı ya da Çin uygarlığı değil
İnsan uygarlığı Çünkü dışarıdan gelecek
herhangi birisi için biz dünyalıyız bu
bir bilim kurgu terimi değil biz
dünyalıyız hepimiz onlar için bu
yarışmada birçok kişi 3 tek tanrılı
semavi dinin
sembollerini kullanarak kendimizi o
canlılara tanıtabileceğimiz kadar dar
görüşlü bir düşünce öne sürmüşler yani
Hilal Hac ve yıldız 3 dinin sembolü bu
yarışmada Carl sagan’ın yaptığı
çalışma kazanıyor
kendisini şöyle belki hatırlarsınız
Kozmoz diye bir televizyon dizisi
yapmıştı
aynı zamanda Jolly Foster'ın oynadığı
Bizde mesaj adıyla gösterilen bir film
kontakt adı o filmin de senaryosunu
yazmış birisidir
benim için çok kıymetlidir yaşasaydı
kesinlikle tanışmak isteyeceğim kadar
önemli bir rol modeli onun yaptığı figür
kazanıyor O nedir biliyor musunuz Öncü
plak olarak şimdi uzayda dolaşıyor bir
kadınla bir erkek ve çöpten çizilmiş
Çünkü dünya uygarlığının İnsan
uygarlığını bir kadınla bir erkek
yapmıştır yani Kadınlarla erkekler
kadınsız insan medeniyeti erkeksiz insan
medeniyeti olmaz Bunu aslında bütün
erkeklerin de sekssiz ve mizojen
olmadığını söylemek için özellikle
seçtim
roman ve öykülerimde 30 yıldan fazladır
kadın karakterlerin de Hakları insan
hakları olduğunu anlatan ve bunun için
mücadele eden bir kadın yazar olarak
kendi hikayemi Tıpkı DNA sarmalı gibi
görüyorum Bu hikayede Benden önceki
kadın yazarlar bilimciler Bunlar ille
Türkiye'den olması gerekmiyor ama
Türkiye'deki çok değerli yazarlar dahil
sanki onların
DNA sarmalarına sarılmışım ve bir yandan
da bir dakika burada çok güzel bir cümle
olduğunu sandığım bir şey koymuştum
benden sonraki kızlara uzanan bir amino
asit dizisi gibi hissediyorum
sözlerimi bitirirken toplumsal
Cinsiyetin yani Cender denen konunun bu
konuda yaşanan bütün
haksızlıklara rağmen kızlarını kız
kardeşlerini annelerini kız torunlarının
yanında duran onlara engel olmayan
erkeklerin de alkışlarımı sunmak
istiyorum Çünkü insan uygarlığı bir
kadınla bir erkekten meydana gelmiştidir
bitirirken de kitap fuarı İzmir kitap
fuarında Bana 10 yaşında sizi çok
seviyorum benim idolümsünüz rol
modelimsiniz yazan masalın 10 yaşında
beşinci sınıfta olan masalın bana
verdiği armağanı paylaşmak istiyorum ve
bununla gurur duyuyorum
[Alkış]
teşekkürler